you see your growth as a staircase your
growth is a staircase and you you want
to climb forever you don't want to ever
stop growing you don't want to ever stop
learning as soon as you feel like you've
stopped learning and stop growing you
start to really hate your life you
always want to feel like you're growing
and learning somewhere so look at your
growth as a staircase and when you're
doing imposter syndrome what you're
doing is looking at the people who are
ahead of you on the staircase and saying
oh my gosh look at that person they're
so much further ahead of me I suck I get
why can't I be like them why can't I be
like Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Tony
Robbins or whoever your heroes are that
you look up to and respect and feel like
they're so far ahead of you and because
you're not where they are means in your
own head you can't do anything you can't
share your message you're not worthy
enough what you need to recognize is
you're still on your staircase as well
but you're not at Step Zero if Oprah and
Elon Musk are at step 8 000 maybe you're
at step 100